[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission ça décolle la
réunion sans réparer alors allons-nous
comment il est
dans sa même
mis pas moins les misérables
dans la commune de Salazie et nous nous
sommes en pointe le sentier scout alors
si nous garde bien départ sentier scout
ici 1652 mètres d'altitude alors et nous
nous on va aller à Malheur 2h30 aussi
sur cette portion là le grand arrêt du
passe pas là et ben nous ça va pas là
allez allons nous
[Musique]
ah oui quand même il a mascaren c'est
combien de kilomètres 70
et au Parlement
préparation là et il est important une
bonne préparation
[Musique]
et sentimentale il faut mettre faut
mettre parce que il est bien le paysage
est bien la forêt voilà mais il faut
bien profiter aussi il faut aller en
bonne condition physique bonne
continuation
[Musique]
ça c'est quelqu'un de l'ENF bonjour
monsieur bonjour Comment ça va très très
bien est-ce que vous me dire qu'est-ce
que vous êtes en train de faire alors je
vais être enlever vérifier les plages
sur un muret c'est un muret très récent
c'est un muret qui a été construit au
mois d'avril d'accord après un
effondrement du sentier le sentier a
disparu le week-end des 2 et 3 avril
2022 le cirque de Salazie a connu des
pluies diluviennes qui de créer beaucoup
de dégâts et le sentier scout a subi ces
dégâts avec un glissement de terrain qui
a emporté le sentier derrière moi c'est
là où il a un rubalisé voilà on passe
bien
passer d'accord ma femme a été très très
impactée par les cyclones et
pratiquement surtout les itinéraires
empruntés par les épreuves du Grand Raid
dans le cirque on a dû intervenir pour
pour traiter les éboulements de façon
plus ou moins importante alors là on
utilise des méthodes ancestrales c'est
on appelle ça un mur en pierre sèche ce
sont des pierres ramassées dans la
ravine qui ont été montés ici en les
roulant à la suite du muret on a mis un
bois maigre qui a été coupé sur place
voilà on appelle ça un épaulement qui a
permis ensuite de s'appuyer dessus pour
construire ces marches en bois alors je
suppose tous ces travaux là ça ça a un
coup non comment ça se passe mais bien
sûr bien sûr que ça a un coût et ce
n'est pas gratuit et il y a un financeur
d'accord le financeur c'est le
département qui est très généreux pour
entretenir les sentiers de la Réunion
c'est un des départements les plus
généreuses de France la passerelle
dillette à bourse que l'on a construites
l'an dernier c'est 200000 euros pour 28
mètres de passerelle et le département
est aidé par des fois européens en tout
cas mais c'est bien du coup j'en prenne
le nouveau passage allez
[Musique]
je vois deux personnes en train de
regarder le paysage bonjour monsieur
bonjour Comment ça va ça va bien bonjour
alors dites-moi qu'est-ce que vous êtes
en train de regarder bon regardez on
vient d'arriver à l'île était malheur et
en regardant un peu si on va pouvoir
trouver à manger ici ce midi
et donc voilà on part juste
on redescend là maintenant on est bien
sur la fin de notre parcours et est-ce
que sur votre parcours vous avez fait
attention aux aménagements qui a lieu
comment vous trouvez l'état des sentiers
du sentier que vous avez fait on voit
que il y a quand même pas mal de passage
des sentiers sont entretenus tout est
c'était bien balisé c'est super super
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez la dire
continue à hésiter parce que faut pas
qu'il y a trop de monde
après s'il y a trop de monde
c'est une super expérience à vivre donc
maximum de gens enfin faut pas hésiter
et venir c'est vrai c'est super Ciao
histoires alors il faut savoir que en
1829 l'avait bonne sachez d'esclaves
c'était le détachement de Léonard
Guichard banana arrive en haut et la
tombe sur un campement marron la vérité
40 marron TV ici en OTA assis et quand
balade à fond de Banana bah là dessus
tout le bon de marron l'avait sort et
depuis cette tragédie là il est là donne
son nom l'Ilette à Malheur ok la Réunion
nana Gaïa allons prendre le temps
vis-à-lit et pour ça rendez vous un
prochain épisode de l'émission à l'ONU
cette fois-ci nous sera dans la commune
de Saint-Paul et ça visite l'état
Saint-Paul Gaïa semaine on trouve
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]